Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Andrego said you, wait, I didn't even recognize you.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you so much for the 20 gifted, and I will thank you so much for the 50 gifted.
What's happening?
I look at the chat.
I look away from the chat, I look back, and suddenly it's just all gifted.
Hello everybody!
Hi, hi, welcome in, welcome in.
Hello, hello, hello, hello, hello.
Welcome back to...
Clover Pit!
Fake news!
Thank you so much for the time, Captain!
Grants on the dank 420K subs, Vito.
Thank you!
I know, we made it to 420, baby!
Let's go!
Hope you had a good weekend.
I had a great weekend.
I hope you guys had a good weekend too.
It's Monday.
Oh my gosh.
Dragon Princess, thank you so much for the five good times.
Just got my plushie!
Vito came to Brazil!
Thank you.
Congrats on hitting 420!
Thank you!
Now you're a green V2 for a more wisdom one.
Whoa.
Maybe I should have done a...
like a chill or a more chill stream do not get the spicy italian from subway well i won't get anything spicy ever in my afterlife so i can't believe you're teaching everyone bad gambling habits what do you mean teacup thank you so much for the vibe gifted wait your profile picture You can never change that ever,
ever, ever.
Wait, you went from...
You went from Shupogaki to the cutest picture ever.
You can't change it ever, ever, ever.
Yeah.
But we...
Why are there so many gifted?
I'm trying to talk to you guys.
And I'm just, thank you so much for the five gifted.
Thank you.
What about spicy fan art?
Okay, that's like...
That's like different, though.
Today's my birthday, Jesse!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday.
Happy, happy birthday!
Wow, we... What a start to the week, huh?
With gambling all my... All my afterlife savings away.
We're... Okay, today, guys, I'm determined.
going to we are going to what's the word oh escape the room i really want to escape the room somehow i've been having some terrible luck in this game i've been having such bad luck i've been trying to test out like different different um how do you say like methods like i've been like you know i can't go maybe I can't go all in on lemons or all in on interest maybe I have to try some spicier combinations such as yeah different builds different builds such as like trying for like a full six six six demon build but I cannot ever figure it out I think I'm stupid or I just I don't pull what I need to.
I don't know.
We might have to try some different methods tonight.
Yeah.
I think there are a few build guides on stream.
I'm sure.
Or steam.
What did you say?
On steam.
I was like, not my stream.
Probably.
I think plain Wi-Fi might be too spotty for stream.
Murphy!
Have a safe flight!
have a safe flight.
You're on the plane?
Wait, you can watch me on the plane?
Whoa.
You probably need a couple unlocks to make builds work.
I have many unlocks.
First of all, though, I wanted to... I actually...
Whoa, my mouse... Do you see that?
Or it's like not... Oh, there it is.
Okay.
My mouse...
No.
Sorry.
My mouse was disconnected.
But...
got the unlock all the cards I think this was the one
of these this one was the last one I needed Joshua happy birthday happy birthday happy birthday but maybe we can just get lucky if you get the 666 you get the bones so maybe we can just get the bones early and grab the key and skedaddle.
Maybe.
We'll see.
Right.
Maybe.
I don't know.
So, I guess since we're just starting off, let's just do a normal card.
Wait, hold on one second.
I forgot to check something too.
La, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la.
I'm ready to gamble my money away and i'm ready to get hit it big today and i'm ready to escape this place and i'm ready to become the richest ghost in the afterworld let's go gambling hoi okay we see we already got
we already got an arm Let's see.
I'm thinking of grabbing that green pepper.
I'm thinking of grabbing it.
Gambling.
Hmm.
What a beautiful song.
Thank you.
D4.
This is pretty good.
I'm not gonna lie.
So I've also... I've tried a couple I've tried a couple builds I've tried like I've gotten builds before where I was like my green tickets my clover tickets were in like the hundreds I was like I was collecting tickets like a mad woman it was crazy I think though I think um either pepper or the d4 would be good to start with this thing this thing always it will sabotage you do not get disc C it's not worth it gambling time especially if it's like you have the thing where it's you i've so many times i'll have gotten a a jackpot and then it will override it and then it will take away my my jackpot and it's so mean it's so rude thank you so much for the free direct thank you thank you thank you if you want you can just buy more charms and toss in the drawers then reset for full bones wait what no
i want to corpse spawns if there's charms on desk in previous run well there were wait actually no there weren't because i just reset my game just now thank you guys for all the gifts thank you let's just let's just go for now let's just have a good time oh my gosh i also unlocked it wait i also unlocked it to where sometimes the 666 takes away all your money like everything you're holding mega jackpot or bust i'm sure you'll get the mega jackpot then because I don't see much bust.
Rude!
Beep, beep, beep.
Again?
When life gives elevens, you gamble them away.
Not much bust, huh?
I swear, one day they'll make a bust of me.
I'll have my own bust.
And then you'll regret your words and your deeds.
I'll have my bust.
I don't know if I should equip this or not.
I'll think about it.
Wait, did I...
Oh, so...
We basically made enough.
They'll call it a statue.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
to Minto.
It's November?
I don't believe in no nut November.
That goes against my principles.
Don't lose it all in one place, kiddo.
I'm gonna get a lollipop.
Thank you!
Non-stop nut November.
Something wrong with being medium premium.
Don't get mad at me.
get mad at me well yeah what i can do is i can do one more and then we can buy the d4 let's go gambling non-stop nimi november so true so so true my favorite my favorite activity wow honestly i've been guys i think this is streamer luck this is like never how my runs go.
Mint's bust finds.
No noise, November.
Can everybody shut up?
My neighbor got a dog.
I think that they think like, you know, the mid-cafe is abandoned.
So, they got a new dog, and the dog just is barking.
The dog is not trained.
And for the past like two hours, it has been nonstop barking.
And I don't think they do anything about it because again, they think that nobody lives here, except I am, I mean, they're technically right.
I'm not living, but I am existing here.
And the other annoying thing that they do is they leave.
So the dog is inside, but they leave their door, like they have like a, like a deck, you know, they leave the door open.
So I just hear the dog at full volume for so stinking long.
Just all
for, seriously, I'm not even exaggerating when I say it was today, it's been, it was about like two, two and a half hours of just non-stop barking.
It was so horrible.
Woof, woof, woof, woof.
I'm like, have a dog, that's fine, but just train them.
What do you guys think?
You think we should take him?
I don't think we should.
The barking is for me, sorry.
I believe that.
Should we take him or should we hold off?
Did your cats relax?
No, not really.
I did have my own door open, too, because I was like, It's fall weather.
It's a nice, I want the fall breeze.
And everything.
I had to shut my door because the dog was so loud.
Reset till you get full bones.
Really?
What?
Take the dog.
I don't want the dog.
Find you cute and funny.
So here's some money.
Do you mean to rhyme?
That's so silly.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Bones suck without the skull.
Okay, I'll hold off.
I'll hold off, I'll hold off.
Yeah, I heard it.
No neglect November.
Get Minky's neighbor to train their damn dogs.
So, so true!
Wow, wait, these are kind of great.
Okay.
I have no tickets though.
Maybe this one.
Let's get some more tickets in.
Way to have no tickets.
Well shoot, early megaphone.
Ah, love the thumbnail art.
Thank you.
I do too.
It's so stinking cute.
246 Wait, this gives me plus 2 When the deadline ends Ah!
Wait, I don't think I'll have enough Lame Lame Non-stop night November My sleep schedule is bad You could Move to Alaska And then it is actually a non-stop night November Wait, wait, right?
Wait, when does it become Night up north.
Mimi!
Wait a second.
Mimi, I dropped by your stream earlier, and you were drawing something peculiar.
You were.
Very north.
Mimi.
Hi, Mimi.
I think I'm winning.
I think so.
Is it my winning?
You think?
I think so?
Oh, let's go, we're gambling, what?
Let's go, gambling.
Pink, pink.
This is...
We're getting, we're getting literal pennies.
Whoa!
It did its job!
Oh my gosh, it was so close.
It was just a...
It's okay, you don't have to explain.
just one at a time moving at a snail's pace a little bit pink pink pink pink pink pink what was that crowbar oh plus three free restarts
let's go gambling hoi
I don't know understand what horseshoe tool out oh that's how many lucky charms you can have so we have two lucky charms right now the most we can have at the moment is seven shadow moses is this a metal gear reference if i say something it's very safe to assume that my brain is metal gear
focused i i say things with metal gear in Let's go gambling!
Oh, come on.
Sometimes the dice is useless.
Like, what are you doing?
What are we doing here?
I guess it's better to have a chance.
I could get the clicker.
I don't even know what kind of build I want to do.
Guys, I don't know.
Money.
I think that's should be every every that should all that should always be your eye on the wait your eyes should always be on the money prize you want the megaphone yeah but um are you gonna pay for it because I have two tickets
um yeah so are you If I end it early...
I think I want to do another round, though.
Got you, girl?
I'm broke.
Me too.
Come on, Pepper.
Oh!
Pepper pulled through!
I love the sound of a jackpot!
Yippee!
Natasha broke.
I'm betting it all.
I mean, you are betting in the right place.
Bink, bink.
Stupid.
Deadline time.
Guys, more often than not, it's really pathetic.
Like, I am very often just...
I'm very often losing in like the first two rounds.
It's pretty bad.
Like it's actually really terrible.
Let's see what we got.
Well, we'll grab this for some free tickets.
Actually, wait.
None of this was...
Well, that's fine.
It's by design, don't sweat it.
What's this one do?
Well, I think this guy would probably be good then, the toy train.
You hit the jackpot, I did, I did!
Symbol multiplier.
I still don't know what kind of build I want to go for.
I guess, yeah, the train doesn't synergize well with the D4.
That is true.
Oh, we could reroll, actually.
I have so much.
Let's re- wait.
Hmm.
What I might do is reroll.
We get something good.
Then I could deposit all my money that I could.
And then do this one.
That's what I'm thinking.
The Skull!
I actually like this guy a lot.
Especially at him with one of the discs.
Wait, what's this one?
666% chance.
Wait, no.
666 chance percent three.
I like that one.
Plus...
This one plus either like the coin...
Is good too.
Yeah, it is Jimbo.
It's good old Jimbo.
Zimbo.
Patterns multiplier.
Sevens manifest more often.
Hmm.
I could get the hamster.
Okay.
I'm gonna go with my plan then.
What I said.
So I'll deposit all my money.
And then...
Oh wait.
Set my coins to zero though.
Wait, I wouldn't be able to do a roll.
Um.
Home.
Okay.
you get one free spin if you have no money yeah i know you get the one free spin
i mean i think i'm like i would what have 400 i would just have to get 200 more
hmm no how do i want to do this i mean i could also always just go for the the base of the clover and the bell but lay
once leave the interest in the tray you're so right oh my gosh wait you're so right okay
wait that's like genius that's actually genius to move think think
snail's pace this is literally when it is time.
No!
My pepper!
My pepper.
That was scary.
Beep, beep.
What happened to the pepper?
You can only use it a certain number of times.
Okay, what was I doing?
Oh, okay, I'm depositing my money.
Okay, hold on.
Order of operations.
We're gonna deposit all the money.
Set to get the double tickets.
Okay, all right, all right.
Deposit.
Oh, this is scary.
It's scary depositing it all.
Not enough cards.
Okay.
Double.
I always trusted your boss.
Minto losing.
Gambling is mathematically impossible.
Oh, Minto winning.
I always trusted you.
Minto losing.
Gambling is mathematically impossible to win.
So true!
It's never my fault!
It couldn't be!
The odds are always against us.
The odds are never in our favor!
Okay.
Let's go gambling!
It's always rigged, except when I win.
And then, it's just me being the lucky one.
duck out there.
This sucks!
Wait!
This is not good!
I want to
reroll, but I'm scared.
I won't have enough money.
Whoops.
You know what I mean?
Grab Jimbo?
Is it even... well, no.
The patterns multiplier maybe is pretty good, but...
I think I gotta risk it for the biscuit.
Don't reroll, resist the temptation.
No!
I have to get, like, 150, you guys.
Okay, wait.
What do we have here?
Oh!
Well, okay, okay, okay.
This one might be...
Wait.
Maybe I'll mushroom.
If we can even get to...
But this one has every last pattern triggered one more time, which might be good because we have the ham, so...
I don't know if we'll get another option at the telephone.
I don't know if we'll get it!
But...
Let's just try.
I can only do what I can do!
I can only do what...
Am I getting a six?
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Guys, this might be bad.
This might be bad.
The game hates me.
Oh, lemons!
We didn't make it to another.
Okay, this is what I do in times of hardship.
Anka!
No, I need one more!
No!
Oh, I should have put everything in the drawers.
You're so right.
I forgot.
Shoot.
Oh, well.
it's we'll lose another one for sure for sure we will lose one do we want to try a card i've tried some of them before but i'm also like a hoarder and i get scared i'm like i'm like oh no if i use it it disappears but this this one wait okay if i lose and stash everything in the drawers
Which I don't know what that is, but I want it.
I want whatever that golden knob is.
It says, for the rest of the run, the debt to reach is two times bigger.
If you manage to open the door, you'll get a golden knob.
I'm assuming.
I actually don't know if the skull key is to open the door.
So I don't know.
Yeah, I only have one try.
Exactly.
That's why it's scary.
I want the golden knob.
You have five of the golden...
That's true, this one.
This one's like so harmless.
Many memories, many lives!
Will we be able to get the door key?
Is it this?
You can spoil.
Is this the door key or is this the death key?
Let me out!
Oh, it is?
Okay.
That's the door key.
Look, this would be perfect if I had done, if I had, if I had stashed everything.
This would be the perfect run.
Wait, this would have been perfect.
If I had full, dang it.
It is if you don't use it to open a drawer.
But I have opened all the drawers, so.
That's the door key.
Bottom right is the door key.
Oh shut up!
I see something dorky in the bottom right.
Why are you guys so mean to me?
Um, actually...
What I'm gonna grab is... We'll grab the green pepper and then I'll grab wood.
I love wood.
They mean spooky.
True?
I love getting the multiplier.
That's why.
Yippee!
Just call me a beaver.
I'll be chomping on that wood.
Planks and boards?
Yeah?
Oh wow, wait, actually that was pretty good.
Maybe I'll do one more and then we can skip the rest.
Let's go gambling.
I like bells runs because they have a lot of good charms.
They do.
They really do.
I feel like I feel like fruit runs are fine until like you'll be like getting so good.
Like such good cash money and then suddenly the rate goes up so high that it's like impossible.
Why are we so mean to you?
The answer is obvious.
Cute aggression.
I forget that.
Sometimes I grab my cat's face and I shake it a little bit.
I think I'll skip so I can get the...
The extra...
Extra tickets.
Oh!
Wait a second.
Wait.
Um.
Oh, I don't...
I don't know.
This compobulates affectionately.
Yeah, exactly.
The middle.
Oh, which one?
Oh, I'm so sorry.
I just realized.
You guys can't see.
I'll, like, go here or something.
Um...
This one's tough.
It's like, on the one hand, you don't need this in the very beginning.
You know?
The one hand, like, the increased charm space by one permanently is, like, great later on.
But at the beginning, it's kind of like...
It's an investment.
But this one...
Let's see, hold on.
What lucky charms do we have?
Because I would probably grab this one.
And I would grab that one.
And then maybe this one?
Because then we could get the plus two tickets.
They are rare, yeah.
They are rare.
Little so that we can get the megaphone for extra charm space.
Do you see the megaphone here?
Because then I would be able to get multiple things, you know.
briefcase then re-roll i guess that's possible yeah oh yeah horizontal this is is like you know you have all these patterns so horizontal excel would be all the way across kind of like like all in the middle like that
megaphone will come okay i'm gonna buy this And then I'm gonna reroll.
And next will be the megaphone.
Trust, trust, trust.
Oh, more money!
Wait, okay, I'm gonna...
Wait, but then I won't...
Okay, I'm gonna buy this.
What?
I want the money.
Oh, wait.
We're pretty good, though.
I'm not gonna buy it.
I'm gonna re-roll.
Oh, disc B.
Disc B, my beloved.
Tickets more important than money, though.
I don't know if you know this, but I die if I don't have enough money.
Save up for the six.
I've never used this one before.
The crystal sphere.
Is it that good?
I guess, well, because I never go for diamonds and...
Diamonds and treasures and sevens.
What if I got the treasures manifest more often?
And then I got that.
But then if I discount it by two, I will be able to get it.
I think I should do the discount by two.
But if I get this...
I think I should... I know, I think I should do the treasures manifest more often.
Because, wait.
I will get three.
I will get three if I play all three rounds.
But then I could also get the luck seven.
I'd go with the one that controls odds more.
I think that's the better...
That's honestly a safer play.
Okay.
Okay, we do that.
Oh, don't buy that.
Don't buy that.
Okay.
I just have to be good.
Oh, I forgot to...
I forgot to deposit.
My bad.
Okay.
We're...
We're brain-edit-up.
The sound effects in this game are really nice.
They're so, like...
So close!
They're so punchy.
Like, it sounds so good.
I agree.
Oh my gosh.
So close to jackpot.
Biting.
In fact, I know for sure we can, yeah, but we'll do all three, obviously, so we can get the crystal ball.
Oh my gosh, this is gonna be my first time aiming for, for like, well, not my first time.
I have tried, like, other builds with, like, I've tried Clovers before.
But I think it's my first time with, I mean, it is my first time with the crystal ball.
Wow, that sucks.
Okay.
This is how I feed my inexistent gambling.
I don't think it's...
It's exist...
It's existent.
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
One second, you guys.
I'm sorry.
Let me...
It's so hard finding a place to put my head here in this...
I'll just move...
I'll just be ahead right...
Actually, hold on.
Hold on.
I'm going to cut myself like this.
I'm going to chop off my body.
There we go.
Chop it off.
Oof with her body.
Okay.
Oh, oh, nice.
Oh,
this is kind of paying off.
off let's go oh my god she's gaming
i'm gonna put my arms down because it's kind of embarrassing it's just kind of floating there
okay okay okay chill out chill out chill out grab i'm gonna miss you this bea come back to me later okay six six six okay my gente thank you so much thank you okay let's see what we got two lucky charms free set tickets to zero we could do that half the base oh ah okay if i put all my charms away this is okay hold on i'm still blocking i'm sorry she has no body is she a ghost This has the chances of lemons and cherries.
But we could put all of our charms into the drawers and then do that if we're going for the other...
If we're going for the...
Treasures and diamonds and things.
Um, we could do the make two random charms store free.
Let's see.
What do we have?
Ancient coin.
Stain.
Hmm.
Manifesting jackpaws.
Let's go.
Thank you.
Got a great head on your shoulder.
I still have shoulders.
You can see it.
You can simply not take the red phone calls for the good ending.
What?
Huh?
Wait.
Spoilers?
Sometimes I wish we could have Minto head bounce around screen like a DVD logo.
Yeah, that'll be fine.
Don't worry about it.
Wait, so if I skip three?
I do like how the voice on the phone goes, He he, he, he, welcome back.
Skip three?
back!
Be right back!
I also need to hit 666 three times.
What?
And one thing?
Oh.
But I have...
Honestly, my brain is so like...
The issue with these types of games is you can get pulled everywhere because you're just like, what should I go for?
You know?
Do I go for this?
Do I go... Do I go for the phone?
Do I go for the 666?
I go for the bodies.
What do I do?
You know, it's always just kind of like...
It's like you can have something that you want to try, but if you don't get the right pulls, then you're just like, ah, what do I do?
I just pull the lever.
So real.
Me too, though.
This is like one of those types of games.
that I truly will just have I'll just like play it and I kind of turn off my brain even though it's a very much of a brainy type of game
it's very much a brainy type of game but I just don't take
I just don't think or oh brand off gun by eye Exactly, exactly.
Trying to think if I want to re-roll the store.
We're little over halfway.
That's true that I have no tickets, but if we...
That's what I was looking for this one.
The middle one.
Even if it is random.
I'm thinking.
I'm thinking, I'm thinking, I'm thinking.
Okay, let's just...
I'll think.
I'll think while I pull the lever.
Thinking pull the lever.
So lame.
Goodbye, Pepper.
It's only Deadline 3 and my brain is already so like...
I'm curious what to do.
I'm gonna reroll once.
Whoa.
Soup.
Whatever five plus patterns you're doing, it's gonna double the value of all the symbols until the end of the round.
There's the seven.
more sevens and ace of diamonds.
Thank you for all here.
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
No thank only Paul.
Vinny soup.
Ew.
Wait hold on.
I might...
Go for the random lucky charm.
Free.
Oh wait, I have one currently.
One ticket.
I can't use it.
The Minto bust happened sooner than I thought.
See, I told you!
I told you all!
You would!
Regret your words!
You'll have two next round.
Yeah!
But there are so many of these cost a lot of money.
I think I will just...
I'm doing it!
Are you sure?
Why are you...
Oh, wait.
This might be okay.
They work out.
Dang, I wanted this one.
Oh, well.
Yes, boss.
Okay.
We can do this.
Let's go gambling.
Okay.
We're a bit of a snail's pace.
Can you call them back and ask for a refund?
I don't think they're not so kind.
Beep, beep, beep, beep.
Uh-oh.
Guys, I don't think we're...
Oh.
Wait, I still have one round!
Oh my gosh, I thought that was it for me.
Wait, oh, I still have one more round!
I thought it was over!
It might be.
It might still be.
Oh yeah, six!
I...
It might be over for me.
Six!
Wait!
My interest!
My interest saved the-
I'm gonna have- I'm gonna be left with like a single coin.
20...
There's no way this is happening.
Sadly.
Bells manifest.
Wait, what is this one for?
Is it bells and whistles?
No, there's no bells.
Increase charm, space by one permanently.
Oh, sorry.
I'm still blocking it.
I give up.
What if I just sit like this?
The whole time.
I'll just...
I'll be...
It's like I'm literally drowning in debt.
Bottom left.
Like this.
Guys, what do you think I should pick?
Okay.
Sit up, girl!
I can't!
I can't even stand up for myself.
Wait, hold on.
I'm gonna fix it.
I'm gonna do this real quick.
I'm gonna fix my setup.
There we go, okay.
There we go.
Perfect.
Okay.
The booster seat.
I don't think we'll make it.
So I'm just gonna increase our...
Actually, I'm...
Well, if...
Wait.
I have no idea.
I could do the value of the patterns.
Hmm.
I'll do this one because I think we need...
Even though I want more space, I think we need more luck.
I think we need everything else.
Let's go gambling.
Okay!
Four!
Uh-oh.
It was so nice knowing you all.
A captain always goes down with his ship.
Freak Phantasm.
Hope you have a great stream that you reached those 50 games by the end of the year.
Thank you!
Thank you.
I think we'll knock out a couple this week.
So...
What did that do?
Wee-wee...
What the money for?
Wee-wee-wee Please!
Ah!
Six!
Wee-wee-wee-wee Wee-wee
Wee-wee Oh, it's really terrible when you do a round and you can only deposit one time.
Wait, I should have...
I should have gotten this for the...
I don't think we're gonna make it, though.
Let's do...
Wait.
Yeah, I remember to store your stuff.
Yeah, I'm thinking, what if I do it right now?
I think I should just do it right now.
Buy some charms and store them.
Move aside, left side, Minto.
My new Ocee is left side, accurate size Minto.
Pass them on to the next Minto.
Well, I have enough time to do it.
I don't think I will have enough time to put all, what, two more in?
I don't think so.
I almost want to, like, keep this out just in case, you know.
You shouldn't?
It's just two, right?
So, does this count?
Has something in the drawers?
I'm feeling lucky.
I wish this book was the one that when you get the 666 it makes your luck really big afterwards.
Oh my god, we haven't pulled a single thing.
I earned 10 coins, everybody.
Okay.
Let me deposit, please.
Put the drawer.
Okay, we should be good then.
Maybe we...
Oh, man.
I'm not in control.
Oh, love.
My cat was sleeping in a sunbeam, and then she started growling and woke up.
How do you plan to take responsibility?
What?
Me?
I haven't been able to watch much because super busy work day.
What do I go?
He said, don't overlook at her.
Luck on this ramp plus a...
A safety loop to stay afloat.
But everyone's soul.
This is the one.
I'll just do normal.
Look at that.
Look at that, everybody.
What's it called?
I couldn't remember.
The safety loop.
Wait, what's it called again?
One arm.
A leg?
What is that?
Two arms.
A leg.
Life raft!
Life saver!
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Yeah.
I wouldn't know the name.
I've got no life to save.
Life preserver.
Okay, so what I'm gonna do...
What I'm gonna do is I'm gonna re-roll and hope for a skull.
And if we get to school...
I can just leave, right?
Charming top left is so good.
Earn one ticket for every three you own.
I own none.
Media Exodia.
Disc B!
I love Disc B.
Disc B is the best because it has this plus seven lock.
I've gotten...
I've gotten many a jackpot with this baby.
Amazing early.
Yes, it really is.
Just wait and then re-roll.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, that's what I was thinking too.
One!
We got this skewer!
Okay, here we go.
One.
Does it make a little man?
Two.
I'm so excited.
Oh!
Four!
This is going to be fun.
It's red.
That's your final reward.
I still haven't decided...
Wait, what do you mean?
No, play!
Wait!
Oh no!
Wait, so I have to make the...
Oh no.
I still have to play.
I have to make the minimum.
We're so burned.
You still need 250k.
Whoa!
Okay, guys.
I believe in us.
I believe, I believe, I believe.
Let's go get the way.
I believe.
Look at
this.
We're hitting every...
Every time.
Every time!
Sure, it's just once.
Sometimes not at all.
Do you think they were gonna give you the key?
Yeah.
Yeah, I thought they were just gonna be like, Oh, you collected them all.
Here you go.
I thought...
Oh.
My machine is so dirty.
Whoa!
You should not become a professional gambler.
I can count cards on my fingers.
Never give up gambling.
I can count!
Three measly coins.
Yeah, one round.
I get it.
got it now 25% that is insane oh my god oh my god oh my god maybe I should have waited
maybe I should have waited because it's pretty easy to to get it's fine you
have to pick it up.
No, I mean the skull.
Like, I could have gotten all the other ones, and then get the skull last.
Cherry, cherry, cherry.
Alright.
Wait, is this enough?
Was that the last round?
Okay, good.
Imagine dying on Deadline 1.
Couldn't be me!
Um...
Hmm...
I'm wondering if I should pick up one of these.
I'm thinking maybe the...
the P... the P bottle.
And then hoping for...
Maybe like a fruit basket.
And then...
D4 is better long term.
But D4 like...
I think...
What?
What is... What are you guys saying?
T4 is more sanitary.
What it, like, doesn't always work.
Pre-charms and drawers at next deadline because of the corpse parts.
Oh, wait, really?
Wait, I didn't know that.
I need to have a big percentage number for a certain symbol for the for the P. That's true.
Okay, we'll go with the D4.
Or I could wait and see what shows up in my drawer.
Well, I'll go for D4.
I'm going to have like one coin left.
Two.
Two coins!
Oh,
I should have.
Oh, I should have.
Oh, hi-oh.
I could do the thing where I don't.
Let's see what else we got.
Red pepper!
Horseshoe!
The clover pot!
Peppa, Peppa.
I could have double Peppa.
Wait, I can't have double Peppa.
I have no money.
Perfect to pair with a D4.
Yeah.
Horseshoe and D4 are fantastic together.
I don't think I want disc C.
I think I'm gonna get rid of it.
It scares me.
What if I have a jackpot and it gets completely ruined?
I think I'll throw it away.
It scares me.
I have a question for the phone ending.
Will that overwrite the ending I'm currently trying to do?
Got my money.
Thank you.
You should get the normal ending first.
White options.
Not red for good ending.
So the ones that add like the devious.
The...
Okay.
We'll ignore...
Since we are already at something that I've never tried before, we'll just ignore the phone.
Or rather...
No.
I will keep getting options from the phone.
But I will, you know, I'll just ignore the phone ending for now.
You might die before the ending without the phone.
So...
Okay, hold on.
What do we have here?
I want the other pepper.
Oh, wait.
This is the one with the cherries.
Have...
Oh, sorry.
Oh, you guys, I forgot to tell you.
Not hot dog!
No, this is serious!
My cat started cleaning himself, and then the other cat came and started cleaning him too.
You've done an amazing job, thank you.
That's so cute.
I love when my cats clean each other.
But I think they both are on, like, a power trip, so they don't want to clean each other, you know?
Because he's just like, I'm not going to be the one getting licked.
I'm going to do the licking.
I'm going to dominate you.
but um i'm on a time limit a little bit i realized i wanted to there was a place i need to go to tonight and i thought they closed at nine and they closed at eight so i i have three hours so probably i don't know how long today will be i know it's so early i was like why is it so early.
Freaky cats, just like their owner.
I think that's normal cat behavior.
God, I beat the push recently on Halloween.
Oh my gosh, they're bad.
Thank you.
I moved.
I'm glad you still got it then.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah, I don't want to be the customer that shows up five minutes to close, but I don't have a lot that I need to get.
Wait.
What was I doing?
Okay.
Honestly, I don't like all three.
of these.
They're kind of tough to work with right now.
I'm gonna hold off for a second.
ATM money.
Wait, did I not?
Wait, what do you mean?
Get ATM money?
I already did.
Oh, hey!
Oh!
Tch!
Ah!
I almost want to get the green pepper.
I feel like luck, we need the luck on our side right now, you know?
Bell's phone and iron trust.
Oh, true!
Oh my gosh, wait, I forgot!
I can't hold it.
Actually, I think that's a good idea.
Or...
It's hard.
It's tough.
one is how much luck plus five i think because we have the horseshoe honestly getting the other peppered like if we get double peppers if we just keep getting jackpots then it'll be okay maybe you know what i mean so bells
and iron is better because you can still buy the pepper next round wait why how will i be able to buy the pepper next round
re-roll jackpots just roll Or roll jackpots, yeah.
Just get more jackpots!
Forehead?
You'll get tickets from the iron.
Yeah, but if it's not in the thing, then I will...
Oh, I get what you mean!
Ah, ah, ah, ah, ah.
So if I did bell...
Ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, okay.
I get the...
I hopefully get bells to get tickets to buy the green pepper.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
I understand.
We only have...
We have two rounds.
Double pepper.
Double pepper, double pepper.
Okay!
Eight.
How much do I need?
Oh.
Guys...
I'm not sure.
We got many...
many tickets.
Double pepper, double pepper.
Beep, beep.
That wasn't so great.
But maybe.
Just maybe.
Maybe.
Maybe!
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
One pepper.
Oh, come on!
So many tickets!
Wow!
Oh, guys, it wasn't a jackpot!
There's no way.
Let's go back on the ground.
Wee!
This is okay.
Z4 Shine.
Thank you so much for the...
Thank you!
Guys, when will the streamer look?
When will it hit?
Okay, here we go.
We're equipping them.
I'm gonna do the same thing as before where...
I might buy the bricks.
Logs and hamsa These are bricks, not logs On everyone's soul This is the run Guys, I gotta get out I gotta get out of here I gotta get out of here This run trust I wanna get the bricks And then I wanna re-roll for the skull But Do I need a full set to get the full to get full drawers
multitasking were those the anguish cries of victory absolutely whenever I win something I go God no God why did this happen to me why me why why did this terrible thing in my afterlife why of all people why did it choose me I said that every time I win Hot dog.
Hot dog indeed.
Minto of great luck.
Please bestow me your blessings.
You will find a quarter on the street face up.
And it will bring you great luck.
Comment.
I found a quarter for good luck.
I'm so glad.
I found a quarter.
Maybe I should, though.
I always feel like having the modifier for the interest is good is extra money.
But we'll get a pepper.
Lucky Charms at the store costs one less.
I like that.
I found a quarter.
Wait, I could...
Well...
How much is it?
Seven, right?
Yeah.
Let's go gambling!
Hoi!
No!
Yippee!
Guys, this game hates me.
I think this game hates me for real.
Aw, dang it.
Aw, dang it, real.
Aw, dang it, moment.
Aw, dang it.
I
wish it were.
Wait, if everything costs one less, then things that are one should be free, no?
Right?
Yeah.
Oh, the honeymoon phase is over.
I almost want to restock one more time.
See if we can get this skull.
Okay, hold on.
I get the pepper.
I restock.
Clicker.
I won't be able to get it, though.
Sucks.
Well, I tried.
This is the run.
You think so?
Don't jinx me now.
I'm counting on you all.
Beep-deep.
No.
Yeah, say no.
I know, I know.
Don't scare me like that.
I'm trying to decide if I want the extra tickets or not.
What do you guys think?
Extra tickets?
Four more tickets?
Yeah, four tickets?
get the I usually like do the deadline bonus in the beginnings because it's good to like catch you up you know 240 what we got here okay oh oh the professional not professional the personal trainer let's see let's see Let's see...
3% of my interest.
If we're...
Because I have the modifier, it might be good to go with interest.
You don't have to get all the limbs at the very beginning.
You can keep them in the drawers until the end of the deadline.
So you do your spin, see how good you're doing, and get some limbs.
I guess that's true.
I'll get the rest later from 666s.
Yeah, that's true.
true oh
yes yes thank you put my pepper away first before because if it gives it to the pepper thank you that's funny how it's like this one has to do with my interest and it has extra interest on it yes yes yes i think also the stain would be well i don't really get like four plus symbols During a spin right now?
No, no, no, no, no, no.
That's a coward move.
But yeah, if you get a 666, you do, if your drawer...
I don't, actually, I don't...
I think it's only if your drawers are empty, you'll get an extra limb.
I would know, I've gotten many a 666.
This pepper?
But it's whenever three plus patterns triggered during a spin, increase the bonus by three.
So it would be luck plus three.
Yeah, interest is very weak early game, it's true.
I've never tried the rotten pepper.
I'll try it.
I also kind of want to get the personal trainer, but I feel like it won't be so good.
we're at right now you know and it sucks that he has to be discarded later unless well
okay we have the personal trainer right
oh whoa guys imagine if this were a jackpot it would have been crazy Oh my god, it would have been a mega!
What?
Beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep.
Wowee!
When life gives you lemons!
I know what happens to me all the time.
It's so frustrating.
Yippee!
Nice.
Maybe?
No.
Lame, so lame, so lame.
Uh-huh, uh-huh.
What that?
Look at that, we have two rounds left.
And we're swimming in cash.
Maybe it was worth it.
Should we try for the skull?
Wee!
I got it.
are putting some effort into it.
I have to recognize that.
But how much more?
Oh, it didn't go up anymore.
Or guess it did.
Yes, it did.
Yeah.
I'm gonna keep rolling.
Maybe I will do one.
We'll see where we're at.
I like to be a little comfortable, you know.
Yeah, I did a wee bit.
my oh my gosh please I love when my thing is so colorful you know once again we are getting screwed over the house always wins the house always wins huh the
luck bonus for the raw pepper the peppers per round though no or is it per deadline
per deadline wait that's that's awesome wait wait that's so good wait what if i double pepper
what if we keep peppering
yeah that's like crazy good too spicy or a peppered or a pepper run oh wait yeah that's right okay let's go gambling wait because of because of the peppers it's good to because of that one pepper it's good to do all the rounds I suppose where
when is my luck coming in hello can I have more luck please I
don't have to go back to zero right after this oh
Oh!
Aussie man, happy early birthday!
Break the machine!
Yippee!
What'd we get?
Oh, I should have done the card where we get the free... where we get the extra roll.
He's gonna get mad at me.
He's gonna be like, Things are going too well.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna... I'm gonna...
Do it.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna make it so that you'll lose all your money, idiot.
That's a spicy jackpot.
What is this?
Ritual bell.
Oh.
Wait, how many...
Okay, I have two slots that I can choose.
Okay, this one's not bad.
Maybe.
Sometimes this one has also screwed me over before, though.
Okay.
Let's see.
I definitely want to get the...
The capitalist.
The raging capitalist.
Could toss the stone.
Yeah?
We could toss this.
Actually...
Oh, this one's...
Is there any of them?
Okay, this one will equip, obviously.
We'll sell this one.
We'll sell the star.
We'll get this one.
And then I guess we could get him.
Pip-pup-pup-pup-pup-pup-pup-pup-pup-pup-pup-pup-pup.
Let's see.
Double your clover tickets, set your...
No, no, no, no, no.
What do I have currently?
That's like...
I guess we want more lemons, technically, is the only thing I've got going on.
We're cooking?
I have to decide this too.
Wait, I need 800 though.
I'll be left with...
I'll be left with, like, 200-ish or something?
Don't skip?
You think so?
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait!
Ah!
Oh, I can't get out of it!
If I say no, then I lose the chance of...
I guess I don't need the memory pack.
Okay, dang it.
Dang, dang it.
Well, it's okay.
Yeah, I just say no.
I think it's probably more difficult if you start skipping, though.
Okay, let's see.
Yeah, we're trying to leave.
I really just have to decide which ones I want to get rid of, like, the diamonds, treasure sevens, or the clovers and bells.
Not sure which boosts lemons more.
If this one decreases the chances of three, so technically maybe it would boost 11s more.
But then these ones are more common, you know.
They're percentages.
Here, let me start the deposit my money before I forget.
But bells and clovers are more frequent.
That's true.
Exactly.
So probably either one works.
I'm gonna go for this one because...
I'm gonna go for the middle one because sometimes you can get some really good items for like clovers and bells.
So...
Okay.
Let's go gambling!
What?
Whoa!
There were like...
More bells?
Okay.
You'll get more bells!
Whoa!
Crazy first pull.
More bells, they said.
Good start, for real.
Uh-oh.
Yeah!
Jackpot!
You gotta risk it all to gain it all!
Whoa!
Yeah!
Me!
Let's go.
Always gamble.
Always gamble!
He's gonna get mad at me.
He's gonna say, you have too much money!
23 tickets!
Oh, close.
Wisps always right.
Wait, wisps always quit before, right before they hit me.
I was just saying you guys are always right.
Jackpot!
Yippee!
Give me them sweet, sweet tickets.
Oh, he's really gonna get mad at me.
He's gonna get so mad at me.
He's gonna get mad at me.
At least I don't lose the tickets.
Gosh.
This is like...
A completely vanilla jackpot!
Nothing special about it.
Oh, he's gonna hate me.
He's gonna say, things are going too well.
No!
My trainer!
He's gonna...
Oh.
I'm gonna get this one.
We'll get the three.
free restocks.
Why not?
Or rather...
Oh yeah, I forgot every time I buy something.
I'll...
I still have one round left.
But...
Oh, the triggers randomly.
This one?
We can get the clover pot.
Okay.
This one is also extra luck.
Empty your drawers.
Oh, true, true.
Thank you.
I don't think I wore...
This one.
I think I'm okay.
We'll throw it away.
I don't think it's really conducive for what I've got going on.
And this one, as well.
Throw away.
The horse shield.
I think the horse shield would be good.
Thank you.
Cloverpot and horseshoe together.
Let's see.
This one only has two left.
Oh, I keep forgetting that one goes away.
This one only has two left, so...
Wait, what about my purse, too?
9%.
Okay.
Yeah, the horseshoe will trigger the peppers more often.
I do want the Cloverpot.
Because it will be crazy.
How many tickets we will be able to get, but...
I still have time.
Let's go gambling!
We might even lose one of the peppers this round if it like, you know, activates twice for whatever reason.
Oh no!
Ah!
See?
I told you, I told you.
That was close.
That was scary.
Jackpot!
Yippee!
Another vanilla jackpot.
It's kind of depressing, honestly, seeing the total you get when you're just like, oh.
That's it.
Okay, okay.
A couple weeks ago, I went to a casino for the first time I saw how fancy slot machines have gotten.
I remember thinking, whoa, this is just like Cloverpit.
He's gonna get mad at me.
Holy cow.
Don't get mad at me, please!
Please, uh, please!
What do we get?
We got a golden diamond.
We've got the naughty dealer!
Wait, if I get this guy...
I could get rid of...
Well, but our interest...
More bells!
Wait, what did I...
Wait, did I go for bells more before?
Ew, Necronobicon.
Pattern multiplier boost 2.
Ew, it's twitching like that.
And more pepper.
Oh, that was the previous run.
Okay, okay.
Oh, yeah.
Take the cross charm first.
This one?
Oh, that's wrong.
Whenever you pick a phone ability, ban it.
When you discard, unban it and trigger it again.
So we could get it.
I'd have to get rid of something.
Get rid of you.
Throw away.
I'd have to get rid of two things, actually.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
So.
I want you.
I need you.
I love you.
And then I could do more bells.
Are we going for a bells run?
I guess it doesn't really matter what we go for.
Heavy rotation.
Re-roll the phone.
You think so?
So why, though?
How much longer did the peppers last?
This guy lasts three.
You're always such a killer!
I'm a killer now!
You can actually stick the clover in the drawer until deadline.
That's true!
Actually, we don't need it.
That's so true.
Put it in the drawer.
That is very true.
Okay, equip you.
stop beeping at me I don't know hold on I'm trying to think everything's beeping at me get this I will I will I'm just I think I will go for bells honestly I think it doesn't matter well I mean it does matter we need like we need like charms that affect the thing that we're aiming to be our highest symbol is what I'm trying to say but
oh But...
Bells get a lot of good charms.
Yeah, it's just a matter of me pulling them is the thing.
So what I'm gonna do...
Wait, I do have to put you away.
I'm so sorry.
Put in the drawer.
Put you away.
Alright, whenever you pick a phone ability, ban it.
When you discard, unban it.
So basically, I would buy this.
Activate the bells, then sell this.
Right?
the order of operations.
Oh, look, see, this is also a symbol multiplier for every five.
Yes, okay, okay.
Manifest bells.
Clover pet is so good, too?
Yeah.
I mean, I have...
Okay, so now, sorry, I sell you.
It's kind of intense.
Clover Pet is great with Capitalist.
I have to get rid of some stuff, though.
I still will buy it.
Because also, yeah, we'll use him, and we get more charms, and...
Wait, what are we at?
We're at 8% chance.
Okay, we need to buy, buy, buy, baby.
The purse?
It's not sick.
6%.
Yeah, I won't go for much longer.
I'll throw it away.
Goodbye!
I'm gonna hold on to the bricks just for now, for a little bit longer.
Okay.
I'll quit.
Oh yeah, that's right.
I'm not gonna skip, you guys.
I'm not gonna skip.
I'm not gonna accept.
No.
Okay.
It didn't get mad at me.
All right.
Hopefully we can get a more pattern or more...
More charm slot.
We need golden bells for scaling.
Yeah.
Okay.
Ah, goodbye pepper.
Goodbye pepper.
It's okay.
we got another pepper to add now we're going for the bone key oh my gosh so many bells but only one ticket
yippee nice I wish I wish we had like a repeater you know that was the personal trainer wasn't it so lame Okay, so now I can add you.
Equip.
I still have a re-roll.
I mean...
But it's okay.
I still...
Let's just try for now.
Let's go gambling.
Hoi!
I can't put my coins in because it'll end around.
Oh!
Oh, it's okay.
That's right.
I don't have the...
Flaming 666.
Yeah, hold off on the re-roll as long as possible.
Because we have the other pepper, we want to hold off.
We want to always be...
We don't want to skip so many deadlines because we got this guy who accumulates luck throughout it.
So...
There are deadlines skippable, right?
Howie!
Guys,
this might actually...
This might...
Oh, might be the run.
I don't want to jinx it, though.
I think I just jinxed it.
I think I just jinxed it, but that's okay.
We're fine.
Keep going, keep going, keep going.
Let's go, gambling.
Come on.
Yeah, baby.
More tickets.
What is this one, right?
The more tickets we have, the more symbol multiplier.
I just gotta be hoarding tickets, I guess.
Oh!
That's music to my ears.
my ears baby yeah wait I forgot to equip the oh well no I equip it at the deadline yeah another one ah but nothing special number go up number go up
goes my pepper so sad whoa thank you lemons lemons oh my gosh
nice pepper pepper pepper damn
thank you thank you let's put away the horseshoe for now because actually we don't We have nothing that is... Well, actually, just kidding.
This does trigger randomly.
I'm a liar.
I'm an absolute liar.
We will re-equip this, though.
Oh, wait.
Oh, I lost... I forgot.
Wait a second.
I forgot I lost something.
Never mind.
Just kidding.
I forgot the pepper.
Yeah, we do need it.
We do need it.
I'm a liar.
I'm a big ol' liar.
Okay, he's not mad at me.
He's not mad at me.
What have we got?
Clover Field!
Uh, we're okay with it.
Bar-barath-barath-barath-barath-rum.
Bar-barathrum.
We got it back!
Wait, what do we have?
Let's- Huge!
Huge, huge, huge!
Wait!
Wait, so we can get two!
Oh my god, wait!
Yo, wait, that's huge!
Okay, I'm gonna get rid of this.
Oh my gosh.
I think I can get rid of that.
I think I could get rid of all three of these, honestly.
Fish for megaphone?
What does a megaphone do?
Okay, I'm gonna get rid of all three of these.
Because we have nothing with a button anyway.
Okay.
And then put you away.
Grab you.
Equip.
Increase.
Thank you.
And then.
Throw away.
Whoa!
Wait, what do you mean, though?
Hmm?
What?
What do you mean, though?
That's what we said we were gonna do.
Huh?
Wait, I'm confused.
They say megaphone- oh, was megaphone- wait.
Oh, was megaphone one of the charm things?
Megaphone is for before you choose phones- wait what?
Huh?
Oh my god, shut up!
You're good?
It's okay?
Megaphone is rare, so it's fine.
Oh, oh, Megaphone also double- Oh, that's- oh, I got what you guys mean.
Oh, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Oh, I see, I see, I see, I see, I see, I see.
Oh, I think it's okay though.
That would have been like...
I think it's okay still.
I think it's okay.
If I die, whatever.
It's just a game.
okay.
I don't think I need the batteries because I have nothing that is for...
Okay, equip you again.
Plus 7 lock.
I just wanted extra gamba.
It's okay.
Watch.
Imagine if I reroll and I had the megaphone.
You guys might actually strangle me.
Hmm.
No, dear!
Okay, good.
It feels good finally depositing my money.
Okay, okay.
Seven.
I'm gonna...
Wait!
The bell ticket.
To have the ticket.
Bell.
Wait, the bell is to have a ticket modifier.
Do I need that, though?
Do I grab it?
Do I watch this?
Yeah.
Yeah, I do have space.
I think I might grab this.
And I can...
I want to re-roll, but...
I just did it anyway.
I did whatever I want.
Oh!
More bells!
What do I want to get rid of?
Sell the disc.
Yeah.
Oh, drawer, clover.
So true.
Thank you.
Yeah, put in drawer.
Yes.
Okay.
Okay, we're good for now.
Let's go, gambling.
Hoi!
Holy moly!
So many bells.
insanity.
Aw.
No.
Don't do it to me.
Don't do that to me.
We need my...
We need this luck to go up more.
Only plus six for them.
Okay.
So scary!
Oh, whoa!
You bastard!
You stole my jackpot from me!
Damn, freaking me out.
It's freaking me out right now.
Why'd you do that?
Let's go gambling!
Hooray!
Nois.
Halloween and over.
We're getting so many tickets.
I love having lots of tickets.
Nois.
Yeah.
Yeah?
So close.
Close, but not.
Does she have the book that gives you extra spins after 666?
No, I do not.
Yeah, there is an item that scales with tickets.
There are.
There's a couple, I think.
Pretty sure.
Oh, no, no, no.
We keep going.
Let's go, gambling.
What?
Yes?
Yes!
If only I had the repeater though.
So
many tickets.
Yeah, we have the bell picture, so...
Getting away, having a way to reset them would be good.
Because that requires the button.
Time to deposit!
Alright guys.
Oh my gosh, we still!
Oops!
I forgot.
My bad.
I completely forgot about my clover pot.
I could have gotten an extra 49!
Oh, well.
The wallet!
No deal!
Number two.
What do we have here?
Oh, restore all charms!
Clovers manifest.
I think we can restore...
the charms.
Well, it's only one left, but...
Yeah, we'll go with wallet.
And it even gives me more tickets.
Rewrall the phone.
Oh, true.
I forgot.
I forgot that I have so many tickets I can just re-roll easily.
We could do...
Oh, what's in the drawer?
Good question.
Oh, the clover pot.
We've got pee.
We've got Ace of Spades.
I think I might get rid of the disc.
Oh, no way.
I might get rid of the bricks.
Yeah, mostly trash.
The bricks are...
Oh, well, yeah, that's true, I guess.
It is a lot of money.
The speculative is big.
Yeah, I don't know what to get rid of.
Why did we get bricks?
Because it was the beginning of the game.
It was the beginning of the game, and I needed it.
I think I'll get rid of the record.
Goodbye.
And then.
The wallet is for sure we need.
Okay.
What is our guy looking at right now?
12%?
Okay.
Re-roll phone for bell chance?
Okay!
Well, doubles the values of clovers and bells.
I could do double jackpot value.
Does double jackpot even that good?
Double jackpot?
I do kill a lot of jackpots.
I guess that's true.
It falls off.
We'll get it for now.
It might be good to have at least.
Let me trash.
Throw away you.
Hum, hum, hum, hum, hum, hum, hum.
We'll keep you for now.
Free restocks.
Oh, let's get that.
It doesn't take up space.
I almost want to restock for like maybe a better bell thing, but...
This might actually be good because we have the lemons too.
You know?
Because we have the lemons with the modifiers.
Having them trigger an additional time would be pretty good, I think.
Well, you got a lot of tickets and no ticket scaling items.
I have...
Just... I have this.
And I thought I got one other thing.
This, I got this.
Yeah, and the wallet.
So we have two.
Is there anything that you guys know of that I should be aiming for?
Like any sort of item that will do with the ticket scaling.
So many.
I know.
You need to recharge it.
Yeah, exactly.
If I do the P, I need to recharge.
Yeah, most of the ones I could think of.
Reroll for Charm Space.
Oh, true!
Let's do that.
Oh my god!
How lucky you!
Oh my gosh!
Insane!
Oh my god!
Holy cow!
I guess I could just equip it, huh?
um equipment for now all right why not let's go 10 out of 10
wow oh we're still at oh sorry just hit my mic we're still at three rounds so let's let's go in wait there we go let's go let's go get my eye the sphere oh oops I forgot to...
Oops, I forgot to press a button.
We're fine now.
It wouldn't have mattered.
I guess maybe it was dumb to use it without having used the...
But the thing is, is they're disproportionate.
I'll show you.
Or am I a liar?
Oh no, see, because this one's 5 and this one's 4.
be the same.
Always look for a battery.
Yeah, I could look for a battery.
This one is for... Okay, it's not for bells.
Okay, I'm gonna reroll.
No!
I like stuff with luck.
Gold star.
No, I don't think we need that.
One more.
What's this?
Maybe you discard a Charbon for the Table Banit.
When you discard Virago, And then that charm respawn it and equip it immediately.
It's a refresh type of item.
It's complicated.
Yeah, I'm kind of like, huh?
So, forces you, the item so you can have more in your max base.
Ah, okay, okay.
So it would be like 11 out of 10.
Got it, got it, got it.
Okay, okay.
I'm gonna reroll one more time.
Oh, wait.
It's only a thousand.
It's so cheap.
I could go for interest again.
Vine soup.
I honestly, I don't even have enough space.
I'm like, should I even...
Both interest and...
Yeah, not Clovers.
Bell.
Or you mean the tickets.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm kind of doing like interest and tickets right now.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, more interest.
I can't...
I don't feel like I can replace the bricks until I have another thing with the modifier.
To be honest.
Like a thing with the bells for the modifier.
Something else with the modifier.
The modifier is big money at the moment.
Replace the iron.
too because we have this guy.
I feel like the modifier is like good to have, but like the iron is okay to have, but it's not necessary.
I'll put it in the drawer for now.
And I might do more house.
Part of me is like oh my gosh, I want to do more interest, but I want more stuff for my tickets.
I don't
know, I'm just gonna go rollin.
I'm gonna go.
I'm gonna go rollin.
Let's go.
Well,
true, the Clover Pot will give us a lot of tickets.
That's so true!
You're so right, actually.
Yeah.
Is this still triggered or no?
Oh, during the round.
Oh, lame.
Um, I'll hold...
Wait, I didn't even grab my money.
I'm my buddy!
I'm so out of it.
They'll sync up.
Now they will, true.
They'll sync up now.
If we are getting more tickets from...
No, okay, okay, okay.
I know.
I'm so...
Rich, I don't even need the petty change that comes from the machine.
Don't pity me.
Wait, where did this modify?
Is it you?
Oh, I do have a token modifier.
Wait, then I guess I don't need the bricks.
Okay, just kidding.
Oh, you nasty lemon you.
I completely forgot.
Okay.
We can get rid of the bricks.
Goodbye bricks.
That's so funny.
Thank you.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Alright.
What I'm gonna do is get rid of the bricks.
Oh, goodbye, my interest.
Goodbye, my interest.
I am hesitant on the iron.
I'll put it in the drawer for now.
We have two spots.
I'm going to grab the pepper because...
Hell yeah, pepper.
And...
The clover pet...
Well, clover pet, we can equip now, I suppose.
I guess it's fine.
Clover pot.
Because I have one more round still.
I just have to deposit it.
I'm gonna reroll one more time.
Another pepper!
I'll grab it.
More luck, baby.
More luck.
Let's go, gambling.
Wait!
Didn't think this game would click with me this much?
Um...
Me neither, to be honest.
Me neither.
I think it's because I...
I don't know.
There's like...
Usually games like this where there's so many options kind of stress me out because I'm like, I can do everything in the world.
But there's also an aspect of just letting it happen, which I kind of like.
Just putting your heart in the cards.
Jackpot!
You also don't have to play completely perfectly.
Yeah, exactly.
I like that, you know, Sometimes you might have something in mind that you want.
But you have to get creative and go with other methods or something.
It's just kind of fun.
What is...
Oh, the iron.
I'm throwing it away, guys.
I'm throwing away the iron.
I think we did pretty well without it.
Two, thank you!
If you escaped, would that count as a game?
completed i will leave that up to you guys i got the clever pot yes i did okay
yahoo not yahoo no he got mad at me it's an ending okay we'll count it then no
No deal.
Oh, we got the battery guy.
Oh, wait.
I gotta check the drawers first.
Golden bell.
Electricity meter.
Every time you restock the store, recharge one.
Oh, meh.
The bell.
Red the purple.
Fortunately.
tell her.
You guys once?
Once I had the thing that was like double your Clover tickets and set your coins to zero and then I had to double your money and set your tickets to zero and then I had to activate the other current phone abilities and I was like well maybe it will double everything.
No.
It set everything and it set It set everything to zero.
It set everything to zero.
Yeah, it was pretty bad.
Calling John Faith to ward away the sixes.
Thank you.
You guys said don't do the red ones, right?
Oh.
Uh-oh.
Oh, I can?
It's okay?
Oh, okay, thank you.
Then why did I...
Oh,
I did one already.
Oh!
Okay, got it.
I'm gonna do half the base.
Yeah, I'm gonna do that one.
Okay.
Beep, beep, beep, beep.
So many noises, I'm gonna say...
Wait.
I'm gonna say no.
No, thank you.
Sorry.
Okay, 2000.
Um, wait.
Let's get rid of...
This is, like, a legendary one.
I feel, though, how many times...
I don't have, like, any restock things.
So, I'm, like, you know, I don't have anything...
Any items that would add restocks to my...
To my...
Store, so I think I'm just gonna throw it away.
It's when you re-roll.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, exactly.
Whenever you re-roll, it restores.
I know, but what I'm saying is, there's sometimes items that you have, like, the restock.
That adds, like, free restocks, and I don't have that.
So, I'm thinking, like, I wouldn't need this.
So I'm throwing it away.
And then we have the fortune tell.
Okay, let me store you.
Put in your bar.
You have eight left.
Yeah, see like the shopping cart where it's every...
Simple multiple.
For every free stock.
And then you earn a restock.
Things like that.
Fortune teller is huge, is it?
Don't have many deadlines left.
I guess that's fair.
There's this little guy.
I'll put you.
We'll keep the red pepper.
I guess I don't really need this bell, do I?
It doesn't give me more chance of a bell, so I think I'm gonna get rid of it.
Am I sinking in quicksand?
Yep, I'm drowning in debt, baby.
So throw away.
It's good if you have a jackpot.
I guess that's fair, but...
I think we can get it again.
I feel like the treasures are pretty common.
I will reroll once!
Let's go gambling!
Pepper.
Oh no.
Oh my money!
Oh, my mind.
Easy come?
I don't know if the easy come part is real, but definitely easy go.
Oh, that really hurt.
Oh, that was painful.
Wait?
Jackpot?
No.
I have...
Pledge defeat from the jaws of victory.
Well, I made it all back.
I got it all back at least.
Oh, but I don't want to deposit it!
Don't ruin my round!
Let's go gambling.
What?
Definitely a setback.
Yes, but we push forward.
Push, push!
Good luck, thank you!
Why'd you guys say six?
Oh, you're trying to manifest a six, six, six?
Quit it.
Oh!
Ooh!
Music to my ears.
Why does the game hate me?
Why does it make me have fire?
666Y, why do you hate me?
Big money!
I think I have to wait, though.
I won't press the button.
Oh, wait.
No, no.
What?
I don't want to... I'm scared!
I think...
I think I'm gonna...
I'll wait that moment.
I think I should... I think I should deposit it.
The clover pot.
Oh, thank you guys.
Thank you.
Yes, yes, yes.
Let's... wait.
Just get it.
Or...
Put it in drawer.
Equip.
Interest will save you.
It's not that much!
I mean, yes, I could lose it all and still win, but...
I'm scared!
Wait.
Wait, I can just win.
Wait!
Guys, did we do it?
It's enough!
Oh my gosh, no way.
No way, no way, no way!
Oh, that's mine.
Oh, hello, coin.
Getting three free restocks at the store whenever you score both Clovers and Bells in a single spin.
Oh, I think I already have that in there.
Cherry, throw it.
Mm-hmm.
What are my lucky charms?
Oh.
Ah!
Take the money and run.
Take the deal?
Okay, I'll take the deal.
Hold on.
Um, I'm gonna take this one.
Why not?
We'll just add some more...
We'll add more... more tickets.
I suppose.
Here we go.
I'm taking the deal.
The banker offers you a key to win the game.
Or no deal?
Deal?
I say...
Damn!
Whoa.
What'd we get?
Okay.
Whoa.
Are you sure you really want that?
Give me all my tickets?
Guys, we did it.
We did it!
Ah!
You asshole.
Why would you give me that now?
Wait, but this run was so good!
This run was so good!
Oh my gosh!
Because of work has been insane!
God, I'm so sorry work has been crazy!
Thank you so much, thank you.
You can keep playing.
Wait, okay.
If I...
If I lose, if I don't have enough money in a run...
You can keep going and just open the door if you can't meet the deadline.
So I can, right?
I could just be like, okay, I'm dipping and leave.
Just leave before the floor drops.
Okay!
Sounds good to me?
What do we got?
Oh, bells.
Bells, bells.
We need more bells.
Oh, what do we have here?
Horseshoe.
Clover picture.
Throw away.
Cherry picture.
Obsessive.
Every last pattern triggers one more time.
That would be huge.
Could be good.
Store you.
And what do we have?
The horseshoe equipment.
And then...
How many do you have left?
Three?
Okay.
Oh, I don't have enough money.
I just realized.
The store is closing soon.
No, I have an hour and a half.
I'm okay.
Thank you, though.
I really appreciate it.
You really don't know when to stop!
Let's...
Wait.
Let's go gambling!
Hi!
Crazy!
Whoa, I got something new!
Look at that, V.
Exciting?
Guys, I think we
We hit, we hit it.
Doop doop.
And again!
Spin, spin, spin!
Again, again, again, again, again, again, again, again, again, again, again.
Alrighty.
Take that.
What did we get?
Wait!
20% chance for any bell to have the token modifier.
Nah, well, thank you so much for the love.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Okay.
Deposit, deposit, deposit, deposit, deposit, deposit, deposit, deposit, deposit, deposit, deposit, deposit.
I could lose it all.
I could lose it all today.
What's that one?
That video.
The earth is dying.
The animals can't talk to us.
The aliens won't talk to us.
The people are sad.
We're all alone.
But do you really need anyone else?
Oh, come on.
I was supposed to get a jackpot.
I love
that edit so much it's so funny it's so good hello Minto hello more tickets more tickets more tickets tickets, more tickets, more money, and tickets.
Big numbers, big.
My number is definitely money is going up.
Oh, oops, sorry.
I clicked extra.
Getting lucky.
I think we are.
Truly.
What is this at?
Five percent left.
Okay, so we're about to lose this one and we just lost a pickle pepper sorry so let's see more don't mind if I do what are you at 17 a pickle pepper if only we were doing a fruit by a I'll try again?
Fake coin could be good.
For PT or calculator.
What is a PT?
Oh, the personal trainer.
Let the number go, Puvio!
Thank you!
User Strider, thank you so much.
As well, thank you.
Thank you, Joaquin, thank you so much for the 50.
Gifted boys, how many gifted?
Thank you, holy moly, moly.
Thank you guys so much, thank you, thank you.
Ew, no.
Ew, yes, I quit.
Okay.
Can't break me down.
Bury me, bury me!
Yippee!
420k subscribers!
I know!
Crazy!
MGSTOW!
Joseph!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday with salutations!
May your sky stay blue!
Happy birthday!
Day to you!
I thought it was gonna be bad news bears, everybody.
Backfowl beasts!
How do I make it go faster?
Do I just hold down the screen?
Oh!
Oh, I think I click.
Maybe?
I don't know.
Oh, it's a setting.
Ah, okay, okay.
Three million!
Oh, goodbye.
Goodbye, goodbye!
Deadline is now, everybody.
Deadline is now.
Equip you.
Care-
Let's see what we got here.
The ritual bell, throw it.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you for $100, 50 gifts!
What is happening?
What is going on?
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
What's going on?
Why?
This could be good.
Double jackpot's value.
We could do that one again.
Jackpots for everyone today Yeah
Not worth Rewrall Okay
Rewrall Bells Manifest More After
420K Sums and I'm bored on 420 Oh my gosh Happy early birthday Crispy Thank you so much for the five gifted thank you bells bells bells we need more bells
i don't think i'm gonna take it guys i don't think i'm gonna take it indeed
okay bar thank you so much for the 10 gifted thank you i mean i have double what the deadline is
though that's true.
Oh you're right.
We still have the key.
We do have the key.
It's our way out.
Perhaps.
Oh hiyo gozaiimasu!
Oh hiyo gozaiimasu.
Deadlines are gonna get steep.
I know this is where it starts getting tricky.
Oh clover pot if you take it.
Wait but I can't actually get out of this so No deal.
It won't let me.
No deal.
Sss.
I so much snafed the queue.
It's so much.
Or is it so snaf?
Thank you so much for five gifted.
Oh.
I misclicked.
Oh my gosh.
That was scary.
That was so scary.
Okay.
Seven spins.
Hooy.
Let's go.
Yeah.
Get my hooy.
more pepper wow clovers huh that's a that's a choice when i've asked for bells and you give me clovers uh oh
i can always feel it in my ectoplasmic bones when it's coming baby oh gosh so scary this game is scary you guys For a 1.5% chance, it's kind of insane.
How often, like, I feel like...
What a thrill.
It truly is the thrill.
Oh!
Oh, wait.
I forgot.
It's a new round.
You always have an out.
One more try!
We do always have an out.
It doesn't feel like... I feel like it's lying.
The machine lying to us?
No.
No possible way.
Oh, I used up all my... Okay, hold on.
I'm gonna equip this.
Because what if it charges?
That'd be crazy.
Oh wait, they are charged.
Is that a jar of piss?
It is actually.
The dynamo is pretty good with my horseshoe.
Yeah, that's what I was thinking.
That was... That's what I was thinking too.
Let's just go for it.
Let's go gambling.
Okay, hold on.
If it's...
40% chance is really good too.
So, if I do that, you know, it's...
Uh oh.
It might be pretty good.
So now it's 80%.
Yeah, so we could just constantly be pressing the button.
You know?
so scary it's so stinking scary
what's my bell percentage 58 58 no no biggie
i'm kind of shocked at how little wait is this like something i need to activate oh oh at the end of each round okay okay at the end i was like why is it not happening.
Uh-oh.
You're gonna make me sick.
This game is gonna make me sick.
I was last in line, so they were all kept you waiting, huh?
That's so fun!
Part of me is like kicking myself or not going, but honestly I really couldn't.
But it looked amazing.
I'm glad you had fun.
Oh!
Oh dang.
I thought this was gonna be a jackpot.
Come to America, please!
Please, I know the US gets so much all the time, but I'm greedy.
I'm greedy, please!
Just a little Metal Gear in concert as a treat!
Did it not do it?
Her greed sickens me.
Please, I'm greedy, I'm greedy.
Oh my gosh, I just realized how much money we have compared to the deadline.
I could lose it all right now.
I could, I could lose it all.
And that's part of the game, baby!
Next deadline is 144 million.
Okay, you're right.
Wait, did I forget to press the button?
Oops.
What is that?
Whoa, what is that?
Um...
This is only for a round, so I guess I could still do it.
Big pepper.
Spicy run?
He says spicy pepper.
I want to see what it is, though.
Oh my god, jackpot!
If you really want this run to take off, get a red phone call, call two time ticket option with the megaphone.
I mean, I have to get super lucky.
And it'll be again, again!
Super jackpot!
Yay!
I love the applause.
Applause, applause, applause, uh oh.
Another funny applause, applause,
another jackpot!
I love having a luck buff.
She let me like, you guys have concerts?
I know, I know!
The US gets so much, I'm sorry!
I'm greedy!
Uh oh.
Holy cow, can you imagine losing it all?
in the losing it all in the final spin
yippee the deadline is now okay this thing is not working am I crazy it's not working at all bell pepper triggers randomly luck zero for current spin increased this bonus by two for every restock done until the end of the deadline oh okay
never punished but that's not true that's not true wait it's 180.
it's way more than we thought i forgot the i forgot the pot again i'm sorry i forgot the That clover pot again, everybody.
That is my fault.
I got a red pepper.
We often say you deserve the world.
Why shouldn't you get everything?
I can't see the reason.
Why does it keep giving me this dang ritual, though?
Get out of my afterlife.
Rip, like, 200 tickets.
Yeah, actually.
244 tickets.
Uh, electrician is so much better than the- I- I- honestly this thing has been useless.
How bad is the rate if I- If I don't even- like it's supposed to be 80%, but it's not recharging anything at all.
Goodbye.
Equip that little guy.
I like how this thing is on fire.
I'll take that.
Oh, wait, the calculator!
Wait, is there a difference between broken calculator and calculator?
I live for these applause, applause.
Yeah, the calculator is great.
Exactly, that's what I'm thinking.
Oh.
We'll put this guy away for now.
We'll buy that.
One is broken.
Is there...
No, what I meant is...
What I meant is...
Is...
They're a regular calculator.
Oh my gosh, a speculative trade!
Don't mind if I do.
Hold on though.
Should be fine.
Yay!
You wanted a scientific calculator instead?
Well, someone earlier was like, you should get the calculator.
I was like, okay.
But...
No, this pepper is good, you guys.
This pepper doesn't disappear.
This is good pepper.
We got it on the PS.
PS.
Wow.
Do you think you guys...
Do you guys think we'll make it?
Oh my gosh, that's how many subscribers I have.
Let's go, gambling, hoi!
You will make it.
You think so!
You really think so?
The Mint who can't sell the world because she spent all her money on gambling problems.
Again, again!
Oh my gosh, this is the most tickets I've ever had ever, ever in my afterlife.
This is why I love playing with you guys.
What a great run.
In this house we say Gambling Solution.
Whispering good luck.
It's so true.
You guys are my lucky charm.
Aw, so close.
We literally kind of I have to grow my nose like three times maybe not like five times as big
I think we'll make it you guys I think we'll make it I think we'll make it I think we'll make it Small nose ten times okay
Oh jackpot jackpot Music to my ears.
I already made it.
Mamma mia.
Oh, again?
Oh, jackpot!
Mamma mia!
Oh, once that was a whine!
Oh my gosh.
Again.
Again, again, again!
That...
The little guy, though, is, like, giving us nothing.
Why am I having such bad luck with these recharges, I wonder?
Oh, wait!
I didn't equip him.
I forgot to equip him.
Oops.
That would be why.
I could lose it all.
The winner takes it all.
The loser has to fall.
Don't forget the pot, yeah.
The minke takes it all.
I wonder if I should activate it, though.
With interest, you can't lose, true.
Oh.
Oh, a battery.
Jack-Full!
The Minky takes it off!
So the Minky takes it off.
And the...
I love this nice, cozy, and chill stream.
Without any worries.
No worries.
No worries at all.
No fear, no fear.
We're too big to fail.
We're...
Until we're not.
Ah!
Wow, sevens.
Those are rare.
Beep, beep, beep.
Calculator.
Chuck!
Puppy!
We've almost...
Is this...
Wait, will we hit E?
No, not yet.
No E yet.
Oh, we still have a round.
Wait.
We still have another round.
Ah!
I still don't.
I still don't understand EU, guys.
I seriously don't.
Gotta get to the trillions.
Yeah, we're only at a billions.
I still don't understand it, though.
I think we'll just keep going.
As is.
Oh, no.
Thank you for always making me smile.
I remember my day.
What the heck?
No!
Hi!
Thank you!
Looking forward to receiving your 3D live version.
E10 is basically number of zero.
I know, you guys have been trying to explain it to me so many times.
I'm just too dumb to understand it.
I'm really too dumb to get it, I think.
My head, like, physically just can't wrap my brain around it.
It's too many numbers!
Wait, did we get the charge?
Oh, we did get the charge.
Nice.
Maybe I'll look it up one day.
Oh, we got the charge!
Nice.
Yeah.
Jackball time.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Money, money, money, money, money, money, money, money, money, money, money.
Money, money, money, money.
You know how to multiply by 10?
Yeah.
Everybody knows how to multiply by 10!
What else do we have in here?
I have a pepper!
Since when?
So the winner.
Takes it all.
Oh, what are you at left?
3% left.
So we have three more turns?
Three more rounds with it.
I'm trying.
I want to get as I want to get as many as we can, you know?
I might even get rid of the pepper.
We could go for a plus seven luck pepper.
I think he did his job.
I think it's okay.
Uh...
Yes, okay.
Alright.
Beep, beep.
Oh, look at that!
Plus seven luck.
At the end of each round, replace all lucky charms inside of drawers with new RAN OD20.
Throw away.
We don't need the wheelbarrow.
1k ticket!
Wait a second.
Wait, raise clovers and bells by their base value permanently for every three tickets you spend and 3% interest.
Wait, wait, wait.
I have so many tickets.
You need to buy a lot.
I would have to really...
This would be a really great early game, I think.
Good with the cigarettes.
Oh, yeah?
Yeah, true, because you could just keep buying the cigarettes and buying and buying and buying and buying.
Yeah.
Ah.
Takizo!
Thank you for the five!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, huge if you get the cigarettes.
So true.
E just multiplies by 10, so move the decimal one spot to the right.
So I think E3 is a thousand.
One E3.
Oh!
One is 1.000.
Okay.
No, I don't mind you guys trying to explain it to me every time.
I really, because I seriously say I don't get it every single time.
I seriously am saying like, I really don't get it every single time.
So I really don't mind that you guys keep trying.
Bells!
Oh!
Bells, bells, we need more bells.
54% bells, baby.
And, uh, put you away.
We can hold on to this, obviously.
I don't have to deal with it.
Let's throw this away.
It would be kind of crazy, though.
And we'll equip you for now.
Wait a second.
No, I think I'm gonna get rid of it.
I think I'm gonna throw it away.
Symbols multiplier.
Next deadline, you're cooked.
Am I?
I might be.
I think so, maybe.
No pop quiz.
Oh, no, no!
Hmm.
It's okay.
Actually, I have to get going soon anyway, so let's just get into it.
Oh!
Wait.
I think I just lost.
Bring a symbol's chances to 60% or more.
Oh, nice.
This was the achievement I just got.
I have to get going anyway, because the store closes in an hour for me.
bells we need more bells
what store I'm going to the makeup store there was something that I saw that I want to try and get it's like a thing it's from this brand called the ordinary and I saw like a review on it and I was like wait I kind of want to try that it's like this how do you say it's like a lip I don't have to go today you know yubi but it's like a lip exfoliator so if you and I tend to get really dry lips around this time of the year and so it's to help with that game never ends when you need to go I know
hippie again again
it doesn't matter if I'm cooked if it feels good that's all that matters you know what I mean What?
Nice sub count.
Say, whispery, thank you.
Stay away from my wife.
No promises.
As long as it's a satisfying feeling like this, it feels good, you know?
I don't care.
I don't care if I'm done so.
Uh-oh.
We were about to lose it all, everybody.
hide your kids hide your wife what year is it pulling that out in 2025
that's an oldie well i'm gonna get a cough drop real quick hide your kids hide your wife
equals d is not thank you
Thanks for the math lesson, Sensei.
Music to my ears.
Again!
Okay.
It's the one thing about the coin that scares me.
But I guess since the 666 takes away all my money, it doesn't really matter.
Yay!
You ain't making it to the store?
I think I will!
Because I'm not gonna...
I'm not gonna live.
Actually, I'll just take care of it right now.
Let's just handle it.
We'll handle it.
I'm not even close!
I messed up.
I thought I was there!
Guys, I made a grave...
I made a grave error.
Let's go.
Okay, now I might really not make it.
Something about minke peeking above the bottom right corner is really scratching the right part of my brain.
Really?
Oh!
Whoa!
Tuck!
Throwing for cosmetics.
I really want it.
I really want it!
Use the key!
I will when I die!
You gotta...
You gotta pry it from my dead hands!
Oh no, again, again?
How do I get the little mint to show up and say hot dog?
I could say it for you right now!
Hat, that- uh-oh.
Evil.
Evil, evil, evil, evil, evil, evil, evil, evil, evil, evil, evil, evil, evil, evil, evil, be gone!
Uh-oh.
I say it every time!
I'm literally like, uh-oh.
Uh-oh.
Again!
Let me die, please.
Put me out of my misery!
Again!
I think this is a jackpot, baby.
Again, again, again, again.
The game heard you were trying to leave.
You're like, don't forget you're here forever!
I forgot this
time!
I remembered last time I forgot to this time!
I got it.
It's fine.
We're about to die, so...
It's fine, everybody.
Ew, the collector.
Wait.
Pattern multiplier plus one for every charm with a trait you have equipped.
That's two.
If you leave, you get an extra game win.
I know, I know.
The game is begging me not to win.
Oh my gosh, you guys, I have to go.
I don't have to.
I could go tomorrow.
I'll go tomorrow.
It's okay.
Double jackfight.
Now you want me to get the double jackpot, is that right?
No!
Now you want me to get it, huh?
Wait, do I have to keep it equipped for it to work?
Or can I put it away?
No, okay.
We can put it back.
Free.
Free to a good home.
Oh.
Guys, we might be cooked, but then we are cooked together.
Got to go before I do spooky.
4.444E1 for you.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
This is so rude.
This is a fun run.
It is fine.
It's definitely fine.
We're potentially cooked.
I don't think it's a potential anymore, guys.
I think it's the real hard truth.
A real falcon blues.
We're gonna die.
I will get another jackpot, though.
Just you wait.
It will happen.
I'm learning so much of stuff like how to do this, though.
It's kind of awesome.
Of, like, different strats you guys have helped me.
Thank you!
That's exactly how I remember that song.
I wrote the lyrics.
Usually what you just heard were the original lyrics.
And then they said, this doesn't really fit the theme.
I was like, what are you talking about?
It's a metaphor!
It fits the theme, it fits the theme!
Jackpot!
Again, again, again, again!
Metaphor for everything!
Sometimes you hit jackpot and sometimes you hit jackpot and you still die.
It's just how it goes.
Evil.
Yo-ko-kai no, I didn't realize you were into slides.
They're Japanese!
Pachinko!
A single six.
I wonder what our multipliers are at.
I'm crazy.
We get the zig, but we don't get the zag so often.
Oh, I was like, what the hell is making that noise?
We gotta wait for the piss, though.
Oh, we are so...
It's so over.
Let's just keep going until I die.
Let's go, go, Billy.
Hoi!
I can't leave.
That is true.
I could just leave.
But it's so fun watching numbers still go up, you know?
That's a lot of money.
Stay if you want to.
Well, maybe I like you guys, and I'm having fun, and maybe I want to hang out with you guys.
I don't know!
I don't know.
Maybe it's fun.
Getting that with you guys.
I'm getting jackpots.
I'm making number go up.
She likes us?
Yeah, I like you.
There, I said it.
Are you happy now?
One more, one more, one more, one more!
Jackpot!
The jackpot sound is so pretty.
It's like addicting to listen to.
Do you like us more than gambling though?
Absolutely not!
Jackpot!
I
love- Guys, we hit E!
Uh-oh, wait.
Am I stuck here?
No, I need to get to 2E.
I need to get to 2E.
2E!
You're genuinely having fun.
Of course I am!
Are you... is that bad?
I... what?
I don't know.
I still don't think it's gonna happen, but...
She's addicted.
But I do have a button press now, so...
Hard to say, honestly.
I'm shocked we've gotten to E with all the bones, though.
Like, crazy run.
Like, it's actually crazy.
I'm actually so proud of us.
Yata.
Yeah, get ready to go out the door.
I am.
Again.
And again.
Yata-y.
We have fun when you have fun.
I always have fun with you.
you guys give me jackpot give me give me give me i'm selfish my greed my greed is a never-ending chat hit the real jackpot tonight wait oh no oh no wait you guys guys am i gonna make it wait i can't tell
but surely we won't make the one after?
You need E13.
Okay.
E13.
We're not in the clear, everybody.
We might be now, though.
We'll see.
Oh, actually, no.
This isn't gonna double.
I don't think we're in the clear.
No, no.
We're not in the clear.
Ooh.
Nothing.
It's hairy.
We are possibly cooked.
I think there's still one round though after this.
Oh!
Never mind.
There was no rounds left.
Bye!
Are you really ready?
You are out.
Don't close the game.
Okay.
Do I press anything?
What do I do?
Click.
Whoa!
What is this?
Zero.
Whoa!
There's more over there.
Three.
Let's go gambling!
Yeah, yeah!
Yeah!
I won gambling!
I did the gambling!
I got gambling!
I won gambling!
Doesn't matter if I was gonna lose!
Doesn't matter if I was gonna die!
Oh, oh, gambling, gambling!
Put my name under that playtest!
Put me in!
Put me in, coach!
I wanna see Mint Phantom right there!
one more game finished are we counting this are you guys okay with that are we counting this
nice me though game finished yeah what did i say never punished thank you yeah okay i'll add it then yippee oh my gosh that's gonna be a couple games this week we'll be able to add to the list hopefully
yeah Friends, family, and pets.
The real jackpot was the friends we made along the way.
And of course, thank you.
Thank that's that.
Thank yous to you guys.
It's okay to have setbacks.
It's okay to fall.
That's it.
Get out of the room.
Oh, yippee!
I wanted the golden knob.
I don't know.
I knew you would have...
I knew you would come back.
It looks like we really aren't done with you then.
I got a golden nose.
Oh, I got eyeballs.
I got another eyeball.
I got Sandman.
I got the bus.
I got the train.
I got the potato.
I got the cassette.
You got mail.
I got mail indeed.
Yes, I do.
Nose.
Eye drawer.
Peridore.
Oh, isn't that like the fear of...
Or it's like something...
They're always watching you?
Depression!
I got depression!
How did they know?
Diesel locomotive?
Steam locomotive.
Oh, that's the seeing faces!
That's right, that's right.
Potato battery.
Music tape.
Immediately gain one extra round for this deadline.
Huge.
Whenever two spins...
Well, these are all from opening the door.
Whenever two spins in a row have no reward, recharge.
Okay, that's nice.
Increase all symbols by their base value permanently if the previous three spins had no reward.
Increase all patterns by their base value permanently if the previous three spins had no reward.
Okay.
The slot machine loses its spark.
Spontaneous luck at the slot machine is flattened to zero.
Lucky charms can still grant luck.
I...
Huh?
I don't understand?
Okay.
Whenever you see the eye and no other patterns during a spin, double the value of all patterns permanently.
For every three consecutive spins where you score either our diamonds, treasures, or sevens, you'll have the eye pattern.
I don't understand this one at all.
Interesting.
Depression build is the new meta somehow.
But thank you guys!
wouldn't have been able to do it without you all so i really really appreciate it we did it i guess maybe i can aim for the quote unquote true end someday
yay thank you guys i don't know if i'll make it to the store but i am gonna end it here so thank you thank you thank you um let me get out of the corner I put my arms up because they're tired of being kept down.
I'm tired of holding myself down.
Update us if you try.
Oh yeah, I will.
Or we could try on stream.
Alright, Princess.
Thank you!
Thank you guys.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thanks for hanging out with us.
No, thank you for hanging out with me.
As they say, thank you to everybody who played.
And to- wait, no.
Thank you.
Thank you to everybody who made the game.
And also, to players like you.
I'm looking directly at you right now.
Oh, you're looking good today.
Wow.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
You're looking- I'm getting embarrassed looking at you.
Oh my gosh.
Wow.
You look so good.
Oh, wow.
Well, oh my gosh.
I'm gonna go- Oh my god!
Hi!
Okay, well I'm gonna go...
Yeah, it's you, Mimi.
It's you, Mimi.
I'm gonna go...
But like...
Don't change.
Bye bye!
Otomi-bye!
Bye-bye!